Hi, and welcome to AlphaBits.
AlphaBits is an outlet for our inquisitive minds.
We can't stop experimenting with new technology, and
we wanna share what we're playing with with
you. We're your hosts, Brian and David. Hi.
I'm David, defender of the Rawkode Academy. I'm
a perpetual learner, always playing with new cool
tools that I'm gonna share with you as
part of this podcast. And I'm Brian. I'm
a developer advocate at Amazon,
and I love all the shiny new toys
in tech.
It's kind of my passion is is testing
out the new stuff and,
seeing what's cool. Alright.
What I'm showing here is my fork of
Bluefin.
So Bluefin is the
the containerized
well, it's not containerized. It OCI based distribution
of link of Linux.
So in a nutshell,
you are pulling containers,
and those containers
are the
the base of the system. So it's the
delivery packaging format for your operating system.
It uses RPM OS tree under the hood.
And bluefin is
at
u blue dash o s
slash bluefin on GitHub.
So I've got this fork of it.
And in my fork, I wanted to make
a few changes but still keep all of
the upstream stuff.
So I found this yesterday.
It's called way pull,
and it keeps your forks up to date
with automatic pull requests.
So I've set it up. You go to
the GitHub app.
Really? Just right here. Go to the GitHub
app.
We open that in a new tab.
It says, alright. Great. And if if I
hadn't already added it, there'd be a button
that says, add this to my my GitHub
user, my
organization.
So I did that, and I gave it
permission to work
on this one repository.
Inside the repository, there's one file called pull
dot yaml.
So it lives under dot GitHub pull dot
yaml.
I told it the base branch is main,
and the upstream is at the u blue
dash o s org,
and the merge meth method is hard reset.
There's a couple different options for merge methods,
but this is going to be the simplest,
most painless option for just getting upstream requests.
So once I authorize that and tell GitHub
actions
here,
I have to tell GitHub actions that it's
okay to allow GitHub actions to approve and
create pull requests. This is a big deal.
Once that's done,
I can go into
the documentation
down here, and it gives you
where is the directions?
Let's say here.
So it tells you the getting started bit.
And the first thing you have to do
is add that YAML file,
And then you go to this magic
link here,
and
we just paste that in. And that tells
you whether or not your setup is good.
So we'll add GitHub, the kettle some lufin,
and it shows
my config here as
JSON.
So it's not going to merge unstable things.
And if there's a merge conflict,
it will label my PRs.
So let's go back to my
my fork here.
And you can see that overnight,
there was a push to
the u blue OS
Bluefin repository,
and that commit
changed
a couple of files. So it looks like
we added some new desktop wallpapers
for the framework series. That's nice.
So I can
review this and accept it.
I'll just approve it,
and
it isn't gonna run. I don't need it
to run the workflows because they're just images.
So I'll just merge my pull request.
And now my fork is up to date
with upstream.
And, really, all I had to do was
approve a pull request. So the pull request
happened automatically.
And you can go in on and look
at the the hard details on how to
set up automation. You can choose
how much it's going to do on your
behalf.
And that's really slick. So I could set
it up to just automatically
merge my pull request if I wanted to,
but I'd like to see what's happening.
So that's where I'm at. Way, it's it's
it sounds really simple, but it's a a
real time saver when
you've got forks that you wanna keep up
to date. One of those super practical,
easy to adopt tools.
Yeah.
Always nice to see. Definitely a big quality
of life improvement for a tiny little tool.
Yeah. Always something that I guess I mean,
GitHub should really just have this baked in.
Right? Really, it should. But it is what
it is.
Awesome.
Thank you for your demo.
Alright.
So
t
is essentially
a package manager,
but it does some things different from other
package managers. One is that you don't install
anything.
You just
run them. So you can run t and
feel free to pick up programming language or
a binary that I may not have in
my machine brain. Sorry to put you on
the spot. That's do you use a twin
for your shell? I do.
Everything I can think of, I'm sure you
already have.
Fuzzy finder, ripgrep.
How about duff? I don't have duff. What's
duff?
D u f, duff. Oh, no. I don't
have that. Okay.
Alright. Let's go with NEM just because I've
been reading about the two point o release.
NEM is the programming language. I have no
NEM command,
but I can run tNEM
help.
And now it's resolving the package graph. And
if it finds a package, which it already
has, installs everything that we need,
can see there it pulled in NEMLANG two
point o
and then we get the help output.
So now I've successfully run a command that
I don't have installed on my machine. And,
of course, now that that's all cashed,
it's much quicker. So I could just do
this. Now that's not magic enough. Right? So
I created another demo.
Bun
Mhmm. Is a command
that is like an MPM,
but faster. And if I run which bun,
you'll see it's actually MIT directory. K. Now
the way that I actually got this to
work is
by creating a symlink.
So we can then take another tool
like
which tea
and sec. Now all you have to do
is create any symlink and point it to
t, and it will actually work out what
you're trying to run based on the symlink
name.
So here,
I can run s h sec or sec
As now installing the seg language compiler,
it gives that a second. And
there we have sec. So
you can use the something approach. However, there's
other ways to do this too. I also
have two directories here, a project with a
README and a project with a YAML. So
let's jump into project README,
which has a README. Md. Now one of
the challenges or problems that the t project
wants to solve is documentation
within projects that tell you what you need
to successfully run and work with the project.
Other tools that do this rely on some
file, like, had its YAML based file. Mhmm.
But then the problem is that could then
drift from the documentation
and you've got two different things. So while
you may update your aquaproject dot yaml, you
may forget to update your readme and then
you've got all this thing that doesn't really
make a lot of sense. However, if you
can just save the documentation as the canonical
source of drift, like a readme file,
then t can work out what you need
from that. So from here,
we can run t sync environment
SE
which will scan or find the README. Empty.
Notice that we have the header dependencies with
a markdown table and pull in everything that
we need.
So we'll let this run.
Now it does spit out a bunch of
environment variables.
So,
you know, the best way to do this
would be to stick it into a DirEnv
and just run like source
t
s e.
So
and now if I run go version, I'll
have go one twenty one because the read
me
said we want go one twenty one.
Now if I open a new tab
and go to another directory
and run go version, my machine local version
of go is 120
7. So
now we have this environment documented via read
me, but I actually like the explicit approach.
So if you want to do that route,
you can use a t dot yaml where
you could specify your dependencies. Here, we're saying
that we need w get an NPM.
And again, we're just running sync environment
and it pulls in
the correct
NPM, which in this case is nine eight
one. Whereas if I go to my own
NPM,
we have nine six seven.
So t's
a really interesting choice for development environments and
magic tooling.
My favorite feature though is this prefix thing.
This,
you know, I don't have to go and
work out how to install them. I don't
have to work out how to install zig
or rust c or Cargo or anything like
that. I could just say t I wanna
run this thing. Go find it for me.
And it does.
Of course, you gotta be able to find
these packages. So you can do package search.
I'm gonna need one more package name. I'm
running out of stuff.
How about that's gonna be too esoteric, isn't
it? Yeah. Too pony. Yes.
Wasentime.
Wasaminophen.
I'm failing
wildly.
There we go. Done it. So you could
use t package search to find things. Now
the pantry is not which is where they
store all of the definitions.
It's not
is not gonna make packages as as homebrew.
It probably doesn't have as many packages as
Aqua. This is a very, very early project,
but I think they're focused on developer experience
and developer environments.
We'll hopefully encourage more people to adopt the
tool, which means more people will add more
packages to the pantry, and eventually, we'll end
up in a a state where that is
feature complete. And I actually went through the
process last week of adding Terraform CDK to
the pantry, and it was super easy. It
was, 20 lanes of YAML. So the experience
is is pretty good.
So does it automatically
manage your
LD
variables,
your package config pass, things like that? And
and does it take care of all that
for you? Yeah. So when you run the
sync environment, it spits out all of that.
I'm not in a project.
You know, it's it's best to everything that
you're you're gonna need. So you can see
here, there's the SSL search. There's some get
stuff. There's the LD libraries. Okay. So, you
know, all the open SSL stuff is provided
depending on what else you're doing. In this
case, it's just go. So, yeah, it tries
to cover all of that. You can actually
do more with the the YAML approach too
where it can not replace their end because
their end is awesome.
But you can also start to do things
like,
Brian.
Set environment variables. Like, go root for example
or Yeah. Something like that. And then that
would come out of the sync environment too.
So
there we go. Right to the top.
So it's cool. It does also try to
support Dart End. It doesn't support all of
the features. So if there is any MVRC,
it will export all the environment variables, but
it won't support it doesn't support the the
macros, like, source up and such. So yeah.
It's pretty neat. That's pretty stuck. Have you
run across
anything that doesn't work in terms of I'm
I'm I'm always worried about, like, the ld
library path, the ld flags, things like that.
If it if you come across things that
don't build,
can't find
the package config bits, anything like that? I
mean, I haven't used it in anger in
production or else like that. I've been exploring
it for the last, you know, couple of
weeks. I've added it to a few of
my projects in my mono repository, but they're
all really simple tools. It's just Rust,
Cargo,
Go.
So
I'm sure there are gonna be things that
are
a challenge, but so far, it's worked very
well for my my use case. Nice.
That's really cool. Good demo. If you wanna
hear why we showed up these tools, check
out the podcast available at alphabets.fm.
Until next week. See you soon.